-I want to know if you want to
play a new game
called "SongMojis."
Here we go.
-♪ Let me see those SongMojis ♪
-♪ Baby ♪
-Here's how this works.
We're gonna be shown
a string of emojis
that represent a song title.
The first person to hit
this buzzer right here
with the correct title
gets a point.
We'll play five rounds.
Each round is harder and harder
and worth more points.
-Whoa.
-You ready for this?
-Whoa!
-Here we go.
Let's see our first SongMoji.
-I'm focused.
-Oh.
-What! Wait.
[ Beeping ]
Guys, there is actually
a problem.
I can't see that far.
-I have an advantage.
-I'm gonna have to
come really close.
-That's alright.
-Should we, both of us,
just come closer?
-Yeah, of course.
-I'm sorry.
I actually can't see that far.
-Before we come closer,
I'm gonna need to take points
for that one.
It's "Watermelon Sugar."
-Okay, see?
That's "Watermelon Sugar."
-It's Harry.
[ Ding ]
-Okay, now I can see.
Sorry. Yeah.
-Alright, here we go.
Round 2. This is harder.
-Okay.
Oh, car -- drive --
[ Beeping ]
"drivers license."
-Oh, my gosh! Hey! Nice!
-Yeah.
Now I can see.
-I'm rooting for you.
-I definitely need glasses.
-Yeah, no, it's alright.
Here we go. Me too.
-Oh, "Walking on Sunshine."
[ Beeping ]
-Gosh!
Hold on!
[ Ding ]
All right, hold on.
Here we go. Next one.
-Airplane --
Number-1 airplane --
-Oh, "First Class,"
"First Class."
-"First Class."
Oh, that's...
-"Number-1 Airplane."
Alright, here we go.
Is this it?
Is this the final one?
-Thumbs-up, good -- good --
good prayer.
"Living on a Prayer."
-Good letter.
-Good letter...
Praying on a thumb.
-Up?
-Finger on the thumb.
-Yes.
-"Shape of You."
-Yes and please.
-Yes --
-Yes and thank you.
-Wait.
-Please and thank you.
-Good job. Good "A."
Good "A." Shape "A."
[ Indistinct shouting ]
-What?!
-What?
"Like a Prayer."
-"Like a Prayer!"
No, you --
♪♪
-"Like a Prayer."
Oh, my God. Oh, my God.
-You pressed the buzzer.
Camila Cabello, everybody.
"The Voice"
airs Mondays and Tuesdays
at 8:00 p.m. here on NBC.
We'll be right back with
standup from Ian Lara.
Stick around, everybody.